excuse me Mr Reyes
he finished scraping the gum off that
lounger or what all right
I feel so out of reach you always land
on your feet bro you're hymen
guys but do not open it you went in to
get us jobs and all you brought back was
a hamburger
okay I don't think it's a burger you
haven't looked
the hell is that
how did you get it to do that I think he
likes me
[Applause]
look at me
almost acquired who said that
okay it's gonna be okay foreign
I I think I cut a bus in half
the Scarab chose you but it belongs to
me
hello you feel for your family
makes you weak
[Music]
the universe is a sensual gift and you
have to figure out what you're going to
do with it
whatever you can imagine
I can create
choice
oh it's like Batman stuff Batman's a
fascist
foreign